hello there citizens of the reject
nation we are almost done with this show
gravity falls john how are you i am i'm
i'm a little saddened now but i'm gonna
pray you know these are precious speed
it up john we gotta get two i'm really
excited to watch the show get through
we're gonna watch season two episode
eleven what's it called it's called it's
not what he seems all right good jeez
let's take someone to get there wasting
time leave a like wasting so much leave
a like and subscribe stop wasting time
hit the notification bell and if you
wanna sync up with us with your own copy
and enjoy the full experience come to
patreon.com
rejects we've got so many other shows
where the same tier you get reaction
highlights
thank you
prepper guys thank you and and gals and
all of you thank you for cutting out
these highlights let's roll the bumper
and start the show
[Music]
come on come on should be just enough to
finish the job
can't be too careful with this stuff
[Laughter]
very homer simpson move stream usage
could result in minor gravity anomalies
can it poindexter i've come this far i'm
not giving up now
what we got here
speaking of anomalies
the gravitational pull on this is
enormous
[Music]
the laptop
hey that's from the titles
just 18 more hours
where's this going nowhere
it will never be revealed because for
like 10 episodes in a row you guys have
been like oh but the next episode's my
favorite
shorter intro that's a good sign
okay so i was just opening random doors
because i'm a creep when i found
something amazing
if it was worth waking up at 7am for
that will be amazing a trailer
[Music]
the lawsuit maker crazy rooftop
fireworks party
not so fast kids there is no way on
earth you're setting off those dangerous
illegal fireworks
without me
you have a permit for being totally lame
well i can't argue with that carry on
oh take that
seriously though we should probably
clean this mess up with water balloons i
don't see why not
to grunkle stan not just a great uncle
the greatest uncle that grunkiest uncle
it's unnatural for siblings to get along
as well as you do
don't worry we've still got plenty of
summer left to drive each other crazy
hey
you got it i'm gonna go refresh my soda
enjoy while you can stan i'll find out
sooner or later today's the day
what is that a ladybug
what the oh no i like how his hat
creates a slap effect
target secure take the house
no
i have a feeling nick offerman is about
to return
clear
he's not some evil super villain we've
been watching your family all summer and
we've seen some disturbing things but
nothing as dangerous as what your uncle
is hiding what
trigger you take the children i'll talk
to the old man sorry to break it to you
kids but you don't know your uncle at
all i see punk
pervert it's evidence
ground team move move break down the
door
or maybe not
[Music]
it's a tag on the police station how do
you plead to these charges uh guilterson
i mean in a guilty um
can i have my phone call
got his report card behind me humber
jackson that comes with a free toy
mr pine is this some sort of possession
situation
[Laughter]
time for a repair guy
to become a repair man
sir your junior yum yum baby time kiddo
meal
just put one in my mouth
let's do this
[Music]
are you not gonna
always wanted to do that
in the meantime enjoy some mindless
reality tv designed to pacify you and
make you stop asking questions i'm about
to make the incision
there's no way stan was stealing
hazardous waste we gotta clear his name
wait a minute the security tapes didn't
stan say he was restocking the gift shop
last night if we could get the mystery
sex no move he's innocent we just need
to think of a way out of here
thank me
[Laughter]
[Music]
call back
[Music]
cyril time stands
yes
backup requesting backup
[Music]
come on dipper we're gonna go clear our
uncle's name now you've done it
minute they're playing with water
balloons the next they're building
doomsday devices your uncle scammed the
whole world you gonna let them scam you
too uncle scam
you don't know what you're talking about
you're gonna regret this
good old safety protocols
[Music]
they're getting stronger of course
that's it
what are you doing to the town
[Music]
it's happening the end times when that
machine activates i gotta get out of
town
get in there raccoon wife
oh
timeless love mabel aren't you
forgetting the simpler solution oh right
so is it a rock or is it a face i think
it's a metaphor
[Music]
you're both right
there it is stan restocking like he said
and the date shows it was last night
it's proof he's innocent
[ __ ]
uh oh uh maybe he's just going to the
bathroom outdoors the way nature
intended
[Music]
and he's old so it would take hours
that could be anyone in that suit
god hot belgian waffles wait i'm alone i
can swear for real
so maybe grunkle stan stole some toxic
waste that doesn't mean he's leading a
nefarious double life mabel i'm not so
sure about that
what
whoa
who are you
i didn't need these unless you were
trying to hide your real identity but
why would stan do that
oh my god what
stan pine's dead
foul play suspected in pine's death
fiery car crash breaks cut by who that
evening is real the real uncle yeah is
he just posing named grifter at large
why would they call him unnamed unless
stan
isn't
stan
creepy that's pretty upsetting
what the
secret code to hideout let me see
that a1 b
c3 i've never seen a code like this wait
i have different vending machines
you've been running your whole life your
time is finally up
bathroom break just give me 15 seconds
[Music]
oh yeah so do you huh
wow
dang
stanception
[Music]
oh my god he's brilliant
here's 100 bucks drive as far away from
the shack as possible and don't stop
when the cops start chasing you
he's getting away
[Music]
obviously follow that cow
all right seuss remember the plan
protect the machine earn stan's trust
legally get adopted by stan change name
to stan jr sue
what are you doing here stan gave me a
mission to protect this machine
and i thought i love snacks zeus listen
uh
oh come on i don't want to fight you
guys this hurts me more than it hurts
you
oh no
more than it hurts you
oh
wow
it's like something from a video game or
a dream
what a nightmare
how would you make it back there in 10
minutes
maybe the reason he has all those fake
ids is because he is a master criminal
and this machine is his master plan uh i
was wrong the whole time the machine was
meant to create knowledge but it is too
powerful i was deceived and now it is
too late the device if fully operational
could tear our universe apart
why would what the clock ever reaches
zero our universe is doomed
it's the final countdown just like they
always sung about
the agents were right we have to shut it
down
why would someone do this
what knowledge could be worth this cost
turn
what is going on i don't even know who
you are look i know this all seems nuts
but i need that machine to stay on if
you just let me explain
oh oh no
you're really losing time man
holy [ __ ] oh
no
what is going on
[Music]
gravity rises
gravity
ascending hurry shut it down
no
mabel mabel wait stop
zeus what are you doing tell him what
it's gonna do
i don't even know if you're my grunkle
i wouldn't believe you but then listen
to me remember this morning when i said
i wanted to tell you guys something
t-minus 20 seconds
what is this
yeah
but trust me everything i've worked for
everything i care about it's all for
this family mabel what if he's lying
this thing could son of oh you're big
dipper
mabel you really think i'm a bad guy
he's lying shut it down now
mabel please ten
nine
i wanna see what happens don't shut it
down yeah let it go
[Music]
i trust you oh my god
[Music]
what the hell this is wild this is
nipple chills right now
oh my god
oh my god
just took a whole new level
[Applause]
oh
is that stan
that's the guy's hand
what
extra finger the author of the journals
[Music]
yeah
is this the part where one of us faints
oh i am so on it dude
[Music]
it's them
oh wow
a nice little epilogue
it's kind of eerie it is the brother
being not mabel and dipper's dad yeah
a little pencil there yeah
wow that was a wild episode that was
really chilling it was intense like
definitely not that funny
but
it was just like mildly amusing with the
comedy some good laughs
but yeah it was really like that
actually got like suspenseful yeah like
what's gonna happen and and it towards
the tail end of that
you know it was while it was intense uh
i was still there going i don't want it
i don't want them to push the button i
want it i want to see what happens
not even trust even if they fail i to
just see what happens
we built it up so much that we can not
see it
yeah yeah yeah and then to have his
brother be revealed there at the end and
then like to know the answers are all
connected to the family in some way it
doesn't like uncle sam ultimately does
love them and care about them yeah but i
wonder if he's semi
evil or thwarted the brother like
grunkle stan's brother yeah maybe or
else it's the kind of thing where like
he took up the mantle after some kind of
you know accident of some kind like i'm
sitting here going okay so is the car
crash real
did uh you know the brother actually
died somehow and then he like took over
his work to try and finish it or was it
like a jealousy thing or something like
i don't believe stan is like actually
evil but no no they wouldn't go that far
no because yeah he does seem to actually
care about them but at the same time you
know maybe yeah maybe it behooved him to
take on the identity but i like the
little moments that you get whenever you
could see stan is actually really
capable of being this guy
who is
actually more clever and gifted in
fighting like when he's taking out the
cops and showing some like
those uh i love characters like that who
you genuinely believe are like idiots
are dumb and then you come find out that
oh never mind they're actually one of
that that's what makes them deadly is
this cover-up that they have yeah and i
thought that was really blue i didn't
even think he stole the the
are the tanks or the uh the barrels of
yeah toxic waste yeah i didn't even
think he stole that i was like okay i
mean we know where he was but i don't
think he actually went and got those i
didn't even think that he didn't reveal
that like oh [ __ ] and then all and the
countless reveals that were doing with
him it was like some stranger thing [ __ ]
it really was yeah yeah it felt like uh
them opening up another portal to the
upside down or something like that and
to see like that it actually has
what looked like some pretty serious
repercussions on like the town and just
the surrounding world like yeah it
crests into this level of like
everything up until now for the most
part minus a couple things with like
bill cipher and stuff like that i've
been kind of contained whereas this is
like this
this seems like things will never be the
same after the like next episode can't
just be like a fluffy fun you know
adventure of the week anymore but the
universe didn't i mean obviously the
universe wasn't gonna i mean i don't
actually know about it obviously my mind
was going like so what if this like is a
completely different show for the next
nine episodes
um
and i hope it just stays serialized and
we got like nine episodes left right
something like that i think so yeah not
too many
now's the time
because i mean i don't know they've been
building up this lore slowly over time
and again i don't know what the uh
i don't know how the structuring with
the network of like keeping you on and
how long you get to tell your story but
i could absolutely see
like the gear being flipped like no no
now we're in the end game of the story
you know yeah yeah it felt really
he's actually getting emotional at the
end like watching
uh dipper turn on stan like fighting
with him pushing him away zeus even
going in and like exciting against these
kids yeah just became like dramatic yeah
like real dramatic
and the guy like even even the the guy
in the when they crashed the um you know
van and he's like you don't know your
uncle i've seen this a thousand times
before all the lies you know like it
really and even even them finding the
evidence of like the car wreck like
there are some things that are like
actually pretty serious
that like crest beyond again like the
audience i feel like this was originally
intended for it's just kind of weird to
go from when you look back at the first
season and where you're at here
like i wish there were more of these
shades throughout the show i know right
like there there yeah there are lots of
episodes where you would never be the
wiser that any of this could be possible
yeah and then occasionally they'll throw
in a thing of like well stan's acted
weird you know
but uh yeah it does make me wonder in
that sense like how they initially
theorized all this because if it does
kick into gear in like the last nine or
ten episodes is just all cereal i'm like
this is a fascinatingly structured show
yeah i know
to be two seasons mostly sort of
episodic all based around this you know
twin peaksy shyamalan leadingly episodic
yeah yeah yeah because you would think
it's all episodic then you find out it's
all connected yeah and there are so many
little things that come back around and
that's another thing too is i keep
wondering like okay so what have we seen
in the past that in the next several
episodes is gonna become like
surprisingly important where it didn't
necessarily feel like it was at first
or things like that you know yeah
all right [ __ ] well
this was really cool this is a great one
this is really great it's very different
you know it keeps that's the way it
keeps coming to mind yeah because that
was actually suspenseful i never got a
nipple chills watching this show
hey but i was like getting chills like
this is really
hefty
and then them all turning on on stan at
the end and then the desperation was
just kind of wild to behold it was like
really cool camera work too
um the way they dealt with the
gravitational pull and um or was it
called the i was watching the anomalies
yeah anomaly disruption or something
like that yeah and like oh yeah
especially when they're in the the uh
holding cell and it's like inception
it's like all
yeah it's like the camera is floating
around and you've lost kind of sense of
where the ground even is like there's
some really creative choices all
throughout the surprisingly and some
good sight gags as always all right oh
next episode's called the tale of two
stans good to know
good to know all right guys well thank
you so much for being here um keep a
lookout for our reaction to the next one
uh before we go let's do a patreon
jean jeter gene
if there's a man of many secrets
at our patreon page i imagine that it's
probably you just considering the wide
plethora of knowledge and interest that
you have
it seems like you would be the guy
but beyond that there is one thing you
have not kept secret
which it is your birthday happy jean day
happy birthday gene jeter you've been
part of our patreon page for so long
such a loyal guy and we've had many
conversations back and forth well john
and i individually with you and you have
been just an absolute pleasant
understanding gentleman
and a wonderful artist as well
so thank you so much for just being you
and all you contribute to our lives to
the arts
and i'm sure to the many people whose
careers you've actually helped elevate
as well so
seem like just a great guy and whenever
we make it out to the east coast you'll
be definitely getting hit up by
us to go hang out take you out for a
drink
go to a strip club and then i'll get
yelled at when i come back home
but i'll be worth it
for the gene geeternator
make it rain on you gene
and then we get on there gene is kicked
out
kicked down push those girls off the
stage and show us your moves gene
see ya bud happy birthday happy birthday
[Music]